the staff is grumpy marin developed hulk
of the android team
I'm here today to talk a little
about the new android 4.4 feature that
I'm inpex and then what's good that epp
epi index
is when you have a specific theme
return from a search you make
through the android device and there
allows links through the visualization
of this content in your android app
Good, let's go and admire showing
Do you guys have a search for
fire fire restaurant and you have one
app that makes restaurant review
reserve something like this
put no one better than your own
application to display your content
It's not true so you do may have
an action that calls a call to action
button
in this case a button such as peeling is
that will directly lead your
cooler app then for example
We are seeing the search here.
side and if the hypothetical the application where
I am showing the information that in the case
it is relevant you can make reservation
restaurant is to invite your friends
share and etc.
How are you going to make it stay?
good app available
What I've been developing is your website.
but you will have to write down then what are
the links of the pages that can be
open for your content displayed on the
application android application light
android that has some understand
filters so that these links are not is
open through the application universe
that the system knows you can see
here link within your application only
show a little more detail
then because of the oab marcia reveals the
link elements is in the head section in
section of your page or also the
same link element but there along with the
url element when mounting the mep site
your site
so the search knows that you have
an action there that will be done by a
Android application and look good is
available he put the relation to and from
android application you will have to
do a sim have filters reminding about
the intention
That one has die linke filter on it.
manifest
so the system knows that
type of link will open in your
app
good staff for more information and
know how you do it example of
implementation will take a look at this
link also fell on google blog posts
developers and also the master blog will
to be able to see what the
examples of usage procedures and there
Enjoy this amazing resource 44.4
You're going to bring even more urgency.
possible the captive the sun will be very
more is integrated with your application
finally it's a new tape that you against
android has to have that advantage there
good
Thank you so much for the next videos.